uh donald trump just announced his new
company tmtg or trump media and
technology group
and they're launching an app called
truth social you can go to the app store
and search for it and you can i didn't
i've never seen this before but i guess
in the app store you can pre
uh install an app or pre um sign up for
it that's kind of a cool feature
and uh they're going public via spac
uh the spac is called digital world
acquisition corp it's currently trading
under dollar dwac the stock went up 160
on the news thursday morning and uh it
was briefly halted around noon eastern
as it became a trending stock on wall
street bets uh so let's break it down
here according to the press release
trump media and technology group's
mission is to create a rival to the
liberal media consortium
and fight back against the big tech
companies of silicon valley which have
used their unilateral power to silence
opposing views in america
initial value of tmtg will be
875 million dollars is also a potential
earn out of 825 million dollars in
additional shares
that would add the valuation up to 1.7
billion
uh
what's your take on this eric do you
think this could in any way be
successful
i i'm skeptical just because
you know the first people you attract to
a super niche
conservative platform i mean this is the
pro you know gab had this problem are
going to be really terrible you know
it's going to be the people
who are really on
the edge and if they don't want to be
censoring people all of a sudden they're
just going to have
a huge content moderation challenge i
mean
it's sort of the argument that facebook
makes right being really big they have
the talent skill they've hired a bunch
of people
to moderate their platform you know
tick-tock puts a lot of work into
moderating itself and
will sort of this new app be able to
will they have the infrastructure or is
it much more
sort of uh yeah wall street bet stock
play i you know
that's my initial reaction i don't know
what do you do you have what do you have
a bull case for this thing
well um if trump
remains off of these platforms right
twitter facebook et cetera if the
um
board of facebook their you know
independent supreme court does not
reinstate trump uh people love trump
content
uh and they will probably create
accounts
like it's that's a website i mean you
can go to a website right now and see
you know why does it need to be
an app and so i would say because the
app would be you know interactive
two-way and then all the constituents
and whack pack around him would be
creating content too
so you basically get all of the people
you know these lost children who were
kicked off of all the platforms now have
a place to live
and so he did have whatever 70 million
people vote for him
10 20 of them still really love him and
weren't voting just because
uh you know uh they they wanted a
republican and not hillary so
yeah maybe maybe they get to yeah five
ten million people
um but you don't know what they're doing
you know there are uh glossier there are
brands that are
oriented around far less famous people
than trump so i guess there's certainly
a draw you know a single really popular
person can build a company around them
but you know running a company is hard
moderating is challenging the people
they're going to attract are going to be
sort of the worst of the worst um right
and how do they get mainstream
republicans
or regular normie sort of trump fans on
there like i feel like there are there
are a lot of challenges and then
obviously trump himself is not a great
like executor you know
yeah
yeah i mean what is it right he's like
universities
trump
airlines everything he touches he's good
at marketing so we're going to talk
about it right now the stock is going to
go up but
our is he you know he hasn't proven any
capability to run a company let alone a
technology company yeah and the
moderation i think is a really good
point because didn't you see
gab was the other one
that uh
on january 6 they banned from all of the
app stores like basically yeah i think
that's right yeah i think gav got banned
so you know they they have some if this
becomes like insurrection 2.0 planning
platform like it's going to get bounced
off of the app stores again right
that's going to be a disaster
i think there's something really
horrible about this as well in terms of
using the spak vehicle because now it's
going to be a money grab
this is going to go you know to 50 a
share people are going to lose money
it's going to become a meme stock um i
could yeah well that's a recurring theme
of trump world right like i mean there
were all these
games to keep donors you know
contributing uh when they didn't even
realize it paying more far more than
they could afford so the idea that trump
world is willing to extract
uh money from loyal followers is nothing
new and clearly something that he's
willing to do so
and here's the thing you know tech
companies generally have a positioning
or a point of view in terms of product
right twitter was these short updates
you know facebook was the news feed
tiktok uh snapchat each instagram
filters everybody had their own kind of
technological innovation
this is done uh it looks like they just
forked master don which is an open
source twitter basically competitor
so it looks like they have zero
technology behind this they literally
just threw this thing together put
lipstick on a pig right and forked the
open source version of twitter
um and they literally didn't even put
they didn't have the courtesy to put in
the open source licenses so
i think this is a disaster my
professional opinion is this thing will
fail it'll have five or ten million
people and anybody who puts money into
it will lose all their money
so
if you're a better in the public this is
probably the worst unless you're like a
sophisticated gambler like day trading
you know how to pump these things on
reddit like i
i would stay far away from this and buy
amazon or disney or tesla stock if you
really like want to buy a stock like buy
one that actually has competent
management
we all know how hard it is to eat
healthy when you're grinding on product
sprints and trying to meet crazy
deadlines well now there's an innovative
food company trying to help
real good foods is one of the fastest
growing frozen food brands in the us
they're making nutritious foods more
accessible to improve human health and
they make all the food you love mexican
italian breakfast sandwiches pizzas and
more
everything is a hundred percent grain
free low in carbs high in protein and
best part made from real food
ingredients they are available in the
freezer section of costco walmart target
and 90
of grocery stores nationwide when i
found out about them i went into my
instacart i went out to amazon they were
everywhere and we've been eating the
pizza it's delicious plus you can get
them delivered same day by instacart
real good foods is healthy convenient
and tasty it's perfect for any lifestyle
plus part of their mission is to support
food banks across the u.s and they have
a goal of donating one million
nutritious meals nicely done real good
foods so go to realgoodfoods.com and use
the code twist for 15 off learn more and
follow at real good foods on social
media or go
realgoodfoods.com and use that code
twist to get 15 off